sophie Turner and Joe Jonas are married  [Music]  [Music]  with this ring  the couple who was set to tie the knot  later this year clearly couldn't wait he  obtained the marriage license late  Wednesday night after the pair got  hitched in Las Vegas at a wedding chapel  directly after the Billboard Music  Awards where Joe performed with his  brothers Dannan Shea performed as Sophie  walked down the aisle in a white silk  dress and veil with a light-up bouquet  of white roses in true Vegas fashion the  ceremony was officiated by an Elvis  impersonator  [Music]  josè bros Nick and Kevin stood by him at  the altar while Diplo Khalid and a few  other famous faces filled the room  [Applause]  [Music]  et caught up with Sophie last month  where she gushed over her soon-to-be  husband it's just like the best support  the best person to calm me down and keep  me calm and if I end up crying I have a  shoulder to cry on so it's good I'm so  happy